hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the park now we're
going to be going on the bumper cars
and i wanted to say that this game isn't
quite what i thought it would be
i thought when it was when i first got
here examine device
all right i'll get back to that thought
cause apparently this is important
[Music]
well i can say for some sort of
certainty that that was not normal
that was one of those abnormal
occurrences and also what the hell was
it
why was i being electro zapped in a
chair okay so to finish my thought i
thought this game was going to be more
open world exploration and it kind of is
like i don't want to knock it it kind of
is but also i'm kind of on a path
here i believe i can
catch you i just got to find out how and
why
and also where the hell i am so like
what what i mean by that is of course
you can go anywhere and i'm pretty sure
there's a lot of hidden clues throughout
the environment
that tell the story in whatever way they
can
but when i first heard about this game i
thought it was going to be like uh
you choose the way you go through it and
you choose the way you unravel the story
and i'm not saying that's bad that's
literally a thought that just popped
into my head and it probably means
absolutely dick diddly so ignore me
and why is that one on
[Music]
hmm how's it getting any power there
isn't exactly a grid up above there
because the way these things work is
they get power by touching the
electrified fence on the ceiling oh good
accident report another one
gray francis de fresna
during the transport of a bumper car
into the arena one of the straps
attaching the load to the trunk came
untied causing a cascade of bumper cars
onto francis who was standing directing
the driver
frances was crushed by the weight of the
car francis was killed
dude dexter claims to have
someone at the back of the load undoing
the straps no one else reported seeing
anyone
the sheriff requested that dexter
provide them with urine samples
double checking of the straps after
transit should be mandatory and drug
screenings for all drivers
the local laborers are very
superstitious and this hasn't helped was
it chad
chad
okay
very peculiar huh
awfully uh suspicious and odd behavior
where did you go
callum this car just came out of nowhere
tried to kill me come on stop playing
games with me
i need you to be serious for one goddamn
second
please calum callum
callum
it's a matter of public record that i am
a failure as a mother twist
once when callum was very small i left
him asleep in the car while i ran an
errand
don't even remember what it was when i
came back
the sheriff was standing next to the car
watching my boy through the window
i didn't like what i saw in his eyes
judgment
he wrote me the ticket without saying a
word just the scratch scratch of his pen
on the notepad
when he gave it to me our eyes met
i know what you're going through my
daughter helen
she just gets some help
help was a bolt of lightning help was a
thousand volts
surging through my veins help is
agony i'd rather die i wanted to scream
i'd rather you pulled your gun and shot
me
but instead my mouth said yes sheriff
oh okay i thought that was chad over
there it's just a
poster of chad okay so that's very
interesting
why what is causing her so much stress
in her life continually delayed by the
incompetence of the builders the problem
is that they are locals and so they
believe a lot of the rumors about what
old man henderson used to do here
what was it and why column old man
henderson that's such a nice name for
someone who probably ate
people they grew up on those tails every
time a bolt comes loose or a wrench goes
missing those fools are crossing
themselves against the black magic
of course that is why i chose this site
over all the other potential ones
solomon island is a nexus for dark
energies
huh
huh i called in a few favors back in
brooklyn and got someone at the local
academy to see if they had any
interesting books about local history
turns out they do and it turns out that
old man henderson has some pretty strong
connections to the brooklyn crowd
perhaps something he wrote will help me
find a piece of the plans that i'm
missing
hang on one second huh
what the [ __ ] you talking about the
nexus for dark energy
it's a theme park what are you doing
why man is that the guy at the entrance
that we were talking to before
mommy is coming kelm my
god oh good that baby's back
i was wondering i was wondering
stay where you are why is there a baby
crying over there
i'll be right with you baby one second
so they are going to close this place
down
it doesn't surprise me you think baby
it's already been
closed well back in 1980 after touring
the park riding the rides and viewing
the startling number of incidents
suffered here in the park it is the
inspector's opinion that atlantic island
park should be shut down until nathaniel
winter complies with all safety
regulations
while i understand that there is a
sensitive political relationship between
mr winter and the senator i nevertheless
suggested that political considerations
be set aside and condemning atlantic
island park the rides at first class
appear well constructed maintained but
the sheer number of incidents in the
park during the last few years and
during construction lead me to believe
that there is something wrong at the
base level of construction and we should
close the park and fully investigate
these flaws
like the nexus for the dark energies to
wit here is a partial list of the
fatalities in the park since opening
only two years ago
family of three killed 14 separate
incidents of broken bones
three suicides suicides a child
seriously injured from the
on the escalator over a dozen children
reported missing in the house of horrors
ah hang on wait a minute
over a dozen a dozen
missing children that have not been
found yet
uh and just maybe we'll close down this
[ __ ] place
a dozen over a dozen at least
13 kids missing
all right and one report of a drowning
but you know whatever
say lobby say love
can i decrease the speed please no not
increase slow it down
i can't handle it my stomach won't take
decrease
decrease okay can i get on it now chad
give me a big hug oh boy here we go
it's gonna go well i'll be sure to look
out for any oh hi
what are you hey hang on a second what
you doing over there
i saw that i saw that
anyway this time it's not going to catch
me off guard when a giant monstrosity
leans in from the window
oh this is nice this is the peaceful
mountain air that i've always been
hoping for also
didn't they say we were outside of
brooklyn why why are there mountains
didn't they say we were also on an
island why
why are the mountains we'll come into
your life for a reason
dad used to say that before mom ran off
after that he mostly just drank
what a wise man things were different
for don and i
when we met i was sweeping the floor at
susie's diner
he came in with some workers but he
didn't try to flirt or
cop a feel like the others he just
ordered a coffee and
sat there watching me
shift was over he offered to walk me
home
i don't know how to describe that walk
he talked and
laughed and eventually kissed
it felt like love it felt like a fairy
tale
i can't tell you if calm was made that
night or one of the ones that followed
i think it has to be that night that one
perfect night
don and i moved in together but then
well
he died according to the supervisor his
safety harness failed when he was
working on the top of the ferris wheel
don was there one moment and then gone
sometimes people leave your life for no
reason
i was three months pregnant with calum
fairy tale [ __ ] over
the ferris whale that you're on right
now
and this is your son's favorite theme
park
the one where his dad died
i'm gonna hold my speculation until the
giant
monstrosity appears out from hello hi
you're not the giant monstrosity but you
look monstrous nonetheless
i'm gonna increase the speed and then
leave out and hopefully this thing just
tears itself to the ground
because i've got some questions
i've got hoo boy i've got
so many questions because okay first off
exactly what i said about the story
and second dark nexus
for magical energies
i don't know no no i don't know okay so
i'm just gonna leave this
on and hopefully it'll just break itself
apart because
it's probably what it deserves at this
point okay goodbye
goodbye abandoned ferris wheel
where are you what was that sound
oh there's still a baby over here oh
oh did it oh it flung oh it flung one of
the wheel cars
mommy is coming calum yeah
yep meanwhile i'm gonna reminisce about
how shitty my life is
hello hi oh okay
goodbye
okay
okay this isn't a game callum yeah calum
come on i'm starting to get angry don't
don't do what
come to mommy callum
don't don't touch what calum
who who's watching me what am i not
touching
a lot of people idolize their children
you hear them talking about their kids
and just the way they talk
their [ __ ] voices make me want to
vomit my angel likes to read
and little johnny is so good on the
piano [ __ ] those people
you give up nine months of your life
carrying them you traumatize yourself
giving birth to them
and then you spend the rest of your life
as their slave
wiping asses mopping a piss feeding them
little life-sucking monsters who take
and take and take until
we all go insane any parent who pretends
otherwise is just dishonest
that's called choice supportive bias
i am honest calum really grinds my gears
and he owes me everything everything
it served the little [ __ ] right if i
just abandoned him
okay calum tell mommy where you are
okay so who is
again who there's some people and i
noticed some dude at the ferris wheel is
that who you're talking about
i've got a ride ticket because i i'm
willing to bet if i came here without
this ride ticket it would be like
i can't get in without a ticket for some
reason
but it's green now i'm going to ride
this one never got around to do it
before
ah okay it's it's your kids favorite
favorite park there's literally five
rides
at your kids favorite park you never got
around to this one
you never get around to one of five n
never all right fine may i could
understand maybe the kid was too
small to ride it you know not tall
enough but
suspending my diff belief a little bit
all right let's get on
that's not the point of this though that
just irks me a little bit
it's not the point of the story though
not the point of the story oh hi
hello sir okay bye oh we need to talk
about
callum what the hell what do you mean
what have you done to him
i that's insulting you and your boy
are everything that this place doesn't
want the antithesis of what we stand for
where is callum the poor
child he tried so hard to do what he was
taught
he left you a trail of breadcrumbs but
the park
is just so hungry uh-huh
tell me where my son is the witch has
him now
has both of you no happy ending here i'm
afraid
just just leave me alone
fool you always were
i i always were a fool either i'm
hallucinating or the dark energies are
starting to get to me
oh no holy crap
okay that's a little bizarre that has to
do with me being electrocuted
i want to get after mr bones wild ride i
didn't even read that what the hell was
that
oh okay
i can't read those words they went by
too quickly
not safe no joke i can taste your dreams
what the hell does that mean hey oh
god well bye caleb
holy [ __ ]
i have no idea i have no i have no idea
i have no idea i have no idea what this
game's message or
main story is and i'm not saying that's
bad i'm not saying it's bad i'm just
saying like
from what it has shown me i have no idea
what the hell is happening here it works
the calculations and adjustments work
the transport and storage mechanisms
seem to be flawless what a wound a body
if only these people knew what they were
fueling so what if a few people leave
the park at the end of the day feeling
dour
so what if the children are more scared
than excited on the roller coaster
this could be the doorway to immortality
and such doorways open only to those who
have the will to find the key
what the [ __ ]
is going on
nexus for dark energies okay
anyway sorry i just had to get that out
of my system a little bit
carrying on calum react callum
i can help you apparently man so
okay so if i was to take a rational
approach to this
let me let me just pause real quick i
get to take the flashlight and i get to
go into the householders next so let me
take a rational approach to this
because i let me suspend my disbelief
for a second
and and get past the weird and try to
tap into the actual story here so
everybody hold on everybody get out your
notepads because it's going to be
complicated
so old man henderson used to do
something something on this land and
it's a lot of land so whatever he
did was apparently on a scale to such a
large amount
that it would have been hard to ignore
by anyone let alone the locals
if there's something on that scale going
on that scared
like just the locals you think it would
have had a farther reach than this which
seems like modern society but again
push that aside for now this other guy
mr winter
came here knowing something about the
thing that mild man henderson was trying
to do with the dark energies in this
nexus
and so his logical conclusion was to
build a theme park
but and that sounds weird but here's why
in my understanding
it was to draw people in to do something
similar to what old man henderson was
doing but instead of
scaring the people he wanted to absorb
the joy
that people were having at the theme
park and kind of suck it out of them
like
like a little filter for all their joy
they're having a good time but then it's
getting sucked into the energy portal or
some [ __ ] like that so with all that
being said
he's trying to use it to do something
such as make himself immortal
and this main character is caught in the
crossfire because
she came to this park bringing her
sadness
and she doesn't have happiness so what
she adds to the park
is actually negative emotions and
negative
energy so that's why she is not having a
good time right now
okay this awaits the witch awaits i
don't know what the hell that means
that is my thought because i try to
rationalize these things and apparently
the witch awaits
and i know that somehow because i talked
to a guy who was sitting
spooning me from behind on the roller
coaster
which was very nice admittedly he has
bruises on his arms
finger marks someone has been hurting
him
i've asked him demanded really to know
where he got the marks but he doesn't
want to answer me
something has scared him into silence he
doesn't dare talk
he's been changing too something
sinister lurks in the darkness behind
his eyes
i catch him staring at me at odd moments
in the night
he tosses and turns and cries out words
that i cannot understand
when i try to soothe him he snaps and
bites on my fingers
i think he wants to talk to me i think
he wants to tell me
but they are watching him every minute
of every day
they are whispering to him in his sleep
changing him
they are taking my baby away from me
i can't save him there will be pain
but i love him and in the end he will
understand why
okay so that kind of confirms what i was
talking about
he came to this park and apparently he
got possessed by something i'm not sure
if that's the right word for it
in this universe but that's my thoughts
so
either this is a distorted version of
reality and she's having a rough time or
this is
actually literally right here
no way it's it it's either a distorted
version a reality or this is
all in her mind and i'm leaning towards
the ladder on that one
i don't think that this could be in any
way actually real
okay the whole town was shocked by that
one
never found out who did it yesterday
evening visitors atlantic island park
were shocked and horrified by the
discover of a dismembered corpse behind
the cotton candy stand
what wouldn't you know appear to be the
remains of a
child discovered by teenagers from
innsmouth academy
who noticed a pair of ravens tugging at
something was it an eyeball
it is a true tragedy when something like
this occurs especially in a place that
was designed to bring forth happiness
and joy
the staff of the atlantic island park
offer their condolences to the family
and friends of the victim and will
cooperate fully with the authorities to
bring this case to rest
so what does that bring the grand total
up to over a dozen plus
one now how many kids i guess this isn't
exactly a missing good this is just
dead what is that this isn't a game
callum
i heard that i'm gonna take you what are
you talking about
what the [ __ ] was that oh
blood hey oh blood oh trail of mud
i should follow don't let the witch pull
me in the oven
maybe if you stop bitching and did your
work
and by work i mean push the witch into
the oven
and i guess that was the whole reason
hey stop step stepping
okay that's weird
poor bastard who did this to him
is he dead he's not actually dead is he
oh okay all right then hello did you do
this
did you do it okay fine maybe i sh
hey hi hi chad oh really oh okay
i i i knew something was up when i
couldn't back up
but uh good thing that was totally not a
threat to me in any way
you almost had me there all right
chad you want to play chad
huh chad is that you stepping chad
huh hello
okay take a pill
i don't know about i didn't strange
bottle of pills
first thing take it i don't know okay
fine
these are mine these are mine they're
mine now
they're mine just as tasty as i remember
i'm oh oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy does that say
destroy reality [ __ ] gravity
let's see is a fat pig but his daughter
is hot
i can taste your dreams i remember that
not safe know that
your mother say no to graffiti
huh all that you love will be carried
away don't leave me here calum
well i took some strange pills
callum good boy
where the heck am i now don't believe
anything they tell you
yeah i wasn't about to start hello
who's that what is that
i'm sorry i'm sorry
oh boy oh where did i just come from
oh nicely did nicely did
i like that don't leave me here kel
callum
dang it callum bam well those worked
okay
don't touch me uh oh okay
hello future times belly button is the
signature of your personal character i
believe her name was mama
every 17th child is a magnet for
sinfulness made omniscient by broken
fires in the coastal strain
we don't believe that the earth belongs
to the battered goats and shamrock
afterbirth only the truly naked runs of
the righteous indignation of savage
by warcross cleavages in the trust
exercise arrhythmia
oman will come to the island bearing the
talisman and he will shelter the seals
that bind the orthodoxy of corruption
only then will priesthood [ __ ] reveal
housewives pontificating delayed
messiahs make skills
for the rescue of tango and cash sweet
the temptress who grips the shaft twists
the shaft
absconding with third aged tits into
fourth age darkness
while gods lie writhing on the shattered
face of the earth
gala has sweetness and grace but her
days are numbered and heavy flated hives
break
before frozen wills and cell graphic
actresses in pencil and paper
pornography
the all-seeing eye will provide
decade-long updates
on this story going forward
yes thank you thank you for the applause
i know that was that was definitely
worth reading
right then and there i'm assuming that
was supposed to be gibberish for a
reason
i'm sorry callum callum
pic pickled pickled punks okay
pickled babies i'm scared okay me too
i'm also tripping balls
that's not good that's not good at all
[Music]
okay time for a nap
well okay
why did i need to take those pills i i
didn't actually see myself taking them
so i'm assuming
just picking them up made things go
wrong
so that that was actually all in her
mind
so that was an example of what that was
and i want to see what's going on here
what the hell was all that
was there really nothing else to that
there's really nothing else to this dead
body over here
that's still over there for some reason
we're not all worried about that
all right off we go then why not
the park is a collage of contradictions
all of its own
no kidding millions of people die every
year in car crashes
and the park has little cars designed
specifically to simulate that action
here the children scream with joy
in the sideshow alley you can walk away
with 15 cents worth of mass-produced
chinese teddy bears
while a grinning carny pockets your
hard-earned five dollars
what secrets lie beneath the sullen
waters of the lake
the tears of jilted lovers the soiled
condoms of illicit affairs
the clotted blood of the lonely suicide
and the face of the witch looms over it
all
i've always despised a toothy grin and
rorty nose
i hate that sparkle in her weathered
watchful eyes
i think callum is waiting for me inside
okay your narration took a sinister turn
as well not a hundred percent sure
why breadcrumbs probably the breadcrumbs
what breadcrumbs there ain't no
breadcrumbs but i'm gonna be going in
there
in the next episode
this is wild this is a wild ride i
i also want to reiterate i am not
bashing this game in any way just
because i criticized some of the finer
points of the story
i'm having a wonderful time i'm having a
fantastic time trying to discern the
mind-boggling insanity that is being put
in front of me
and it is really cool but i just wanted
to point that out so people don't think
that i'm being mean to this game
i'm being playfully bantery to this game
but not mean
not no meanness intended this is
actually pretty cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching i'll get
to the next part very soon
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye